we have become the largest party
so I also think I should have become Prime Minister Uhm
I also told the untreatment bar Uhm
that I think it should be me and that I
well you know it
that it cannot be taken from your uh
but there you need the form of support from all parties
and that
well i don't go
I'm not going to mention names
then you have to find out for yourself
but there was 1 party that said goodbye
and that was Mrs. van De Plas's party who said
uh fine uh as far as I'm concerned you can become it
there was 1 party that said
uh well we'd rather not have it
but we are not going to present it
and there was 1 party that said
Uhm in the extra parlamentation uh form uh
no question of that
so i like it
actually not really uh as it should be in democracy
so even though never or 1912
I had come to the side this morning
that the leader of the largest party is not the prime minister
but ultimately you have to make the choice
Uhm is your own position as Prime Minister Uhm
where many people
voted in favor
and also expect that it would be me
and I also understand all those people
I am just as angry as she is
Uhm or do you choose Uhm
Uhm yes then but Uhm
again if it can't be like it
should uh then it should go as it can
so ultimately
no matter how much it hurts
and no matter how unjust I find it
and no matter how Uhm constitutional law it is
Uhm I made the weighting anyway
uh but not to choose my own position
I saw 1 tweet yesterday
that the national interest and the love for my voter
and the PVV voter
our voters
and that it is larger than my own position